ich würde sagen wir beginn einfach dann
war mit dem
der sitzung also wir haben heute einen
sehr interessanten denker vorgenommen
der im grenzbereich von theorie und
philosophie ist und bevor wir uns mit
kirchenchor jetzt genauer befassen
wollten wir noch hier einen chris machen
und ihn und zwar ein quiz über theorien
des bösen und das sieht so aus sie haben
hier als immer falls sie es nicht schon
selbst gelöst haben zu hause
ich habe den linken herumgeschickt sie
haben immer eine oder mehrere
möglichkeiten haben sie ich machte auch
mal so diese stimme rein ich habe ja
sogar auch eine professionelle
sprecherin engagiert die das ganze ein
gesprochen hatte und jetzt sagen sie
einfach mal was bedeutet dass post lazar
ist die situation des menschen vor dem
sündenfall wie die situation des
menschen nach dem sündenfall c die
schlange im baum der erkenntnis die die
tatsache dass wir alle einen alten adam
in uns haben
diese an
die un gehen
ja
warum b und die vielleicht eine kurze
begründung
freilich gemacht
nachdem
das war der fall
nach der wahl
gefallen ist
gut sehr gut genau hast du dem was
hinzuzufügen
also waren auch andere meldungen gibt es
noch andere vorschläge sind sie damit
einverstanden gehen wir's einfach auf
senden und es ist richtig wie sie sehen
hier und jetzt geht es weiter
nächste frage was versteht man unter
einer perversion theorie des bösen
ich denke es geht auch so das böse ist
eine privat ion b das böse ist nicht
durch unvollkommenheit angemessen
charakterisiert sie das böse
es steht eine aktive verkehrung des
guten die das böse resultiert aus einer
schwäche was würden sie sagen ist hier
zu treffen
[Musik]
ja
da
diese
was alle
rang 51
richtig
ja meinten sie schopenhauer schopenhauer
ist es ein bisschen unklar dann hatten
wir ein bisschen offen gelassen
schopenhauer ist ja auch so einer der
das böse gar nicht so richtig pc
moralischen sinne behandelt wie mir
schien der hatte er so dass schlechte
allgemein aber ich glaube wie sie die
auswahl getroffen haben das ist glaube
ich sehr zutreffend also es besteht dann
aktive verkehrung des guten schwächer
ist es nicht dass ihre privaten und
prävention passt sowieso nicht als es
ist richtig gut
[Musik]
nächste frage worin besteht nach
augustinus die sünde die sünde und der
sünde wegen zu tun wie das siebte gebot
um des verbots wegen zu übertreten 10
einen dunklen gegen prinzip zum licht
die in der eigenen freien entscheidung
ja
ja genau gibt es vielleicht noch eine
weitere antwort möglichkeit die also es
richtig die beiden sind richtig gibt es
vielleicht noch eine
genau warum b was wäre der grund dafür
es ist ein fall davon gelten also die b
wäre ein fall von a als die sünde ist
eben gegen das gebot zu handeln und dann
ist es dasselbe und jetzt schauen wir
auf das steht in einem dunklen gegen
prinzip zum licht kann es nicht bestehen
das wäre der mann nicht er ist muss es
ja wissen ja das ist also augustinus ist
ja gerade gegen diesen mann ist zwischen
auffassung gerichtet nächste frage
welche auffassung vertritt der pianist
muss die auffassung dass es ein gutes
und ein böses prinzip gibt wie die
auffassung dass wir aus eigener kraft
das gut tun können sie die auffassung
dass wir nicht ohne hilfe ohne gottes
hilfe das gute tun können die die
auffassung dass wir ohne gottes hilfe
von bösen erlöst werden können sie
nochmal ja
g&d genau
ja ja wir sehen sie die anderen sondern
noch ankreuzen
sie hatten sich noch gemeldet was würde
hätte wollten sie dasselbe sagen ja den
gewinn zweier service saga ist es
ziemlich wahrscheinlich dass es richtig
ist und es ist tatsächlich richtig das
wäre wieder per agieren nicht es muss
die tester wie jeder folgenden thesen
vertritt mutter habe können aus eigener
kraft das gute tun wie der mensch kann
nur schlechtes tun und wollen wir haben
keinen freien willen die der menschen
ist im guten wie im bösen dem teufel
unterworfen jetzt wird schwierig
ja die was also erstmal sie haben jetzt
ausgelassen was ist der grund warum sie
ausgelassen haben warum darf jetzt nicht
angekreuzt werden haben sie da seine
intuition oder alle teilnehmer
[Musik]
prof
sehen
oder
ja und jetzt beziehen sie das mal auf
die frage die auf den punkt die mit
diesem freitag
danke
lingen
sie würden sagen die iren nicht sie
würden sagen also der mensch ist nur dem
teufel unterworfen im bösen sind ein
spiel handelt dann wird er vom teufel
geritten und wenn er gut handelt dann
könnte er nicht vom teufel geritten
werden würden
und wie verhält sich das zb der mensch
kann so schlechtes tun wollen
wie würden sie das damit in verbindung
setzen
ich muss da der mensch verstanden werden
der mensch jetzt nicht als ein reittier
sondern der mensch als mensch als der
mensch aus eigener kraft der mensch
wieder glaubt alleine handeln zu können
ohne die hilfe gottes
hier kann der router eben nur das
schlechte tun
so verstehe ich später wie siehst du es
ist es richtig von mir also wenn der
mensch leben glaubt er könne allein
aufgrund seiner freiheit
aufgrund seiner subjektivität das gute
tun oder überhaupt handeln dann sagt
jutta kann eigentlich nur das schlechte
hervorbringen
sicher sagen kann
ganz gutes tut aber er kann sich nicht
darauf verlassen dass das system ish da
kann seine kapazität eine dunkelheit
eventuell kann tut gutes und schlechtes
aber er weiß nicht ob das was er gutes
mittel auch tatsächlich
das ist
entschieden war
ja also ich denke und natürlich nicht
weil das wäre ja die these des penis
muss wir können es aus eigener kraft tun
was mir halt bei luther mich immer so
ein bisschen irritiert hat war luther
war doch augustiner mündig augustiner
eremitin erfurt bekannte augustinus sehr
gut und er wird eben doch durchaus
einiges auch für zu verdanken gehabt
haben
augustinus ist natürlich auch kein
plagiat
das ist klar aber macht die menschliche
freiheit stärker als luther es tut dass
das frage ich mich immer wie die kam
lothar dazu diese freiheit so zu
bestreiten wahrscheinlich eher die
freiheit zum guten oder dass er sagt
also die freiheit zum guten das geht
halt nicht augustinus china ein bisschen
optimistischer zu sein als mutter aber
gibt natürlich wieder die sünden die
erbsünde lehren
eine verschärfung eben auch eine
verschärfung ist eine psychologische
verschärfung mutter fürchtete er immer
so das ende der welt und der teufel war
dann im papst irgendwann für ihn
sichtbar und so weiter in so einer
situation befand sich augustinus
wahrscheinlich nicht könnte ich mir
vorstelle
die sich auf der
statt wie budgetiert
es sind
die
bis in den morgen
sind mutter überhaupt nicht
klar
so aber grundsätzlich ist letzter
das spiel wieder
stimmt also luther mochte plattform mehr
als augustinussen wegen der
unsterblichkeit der seele auf augustin
ist für aristoteles meine jetzt auch als
mutter mochte war schon mehr als
aristoteles weil aristoteles die
unsterblichkeit der seele nicht direkt
sitzen seine philosophie enthalten hatte
ok spannend also wir klicken jetzt
einfach nur auf senden und es ist
richtig sagte computer jedenfalls und
die nächste frage also welche der
folgenden thesen vertritt leibnitz h das
böse liegt in der idealen natur des
geschäfts begründet und ideale natur
sitzen zitat wie das böse hat den status
der trägheit c das böse ist ein dunkles
gegen prinzip die das böse ist die
mahnung metaphysik um fundieren
sie können einfach mal einzelne punkte
nennen die in plausibel erscheinen oder
ein punkt der sich falsch ist ja
wie sieht sie aus
nicht zuletzt ist kein manche besitzer
aus
sie nicken was spricht dafür
zu sagen
gekommen sein sollen
sein
genau das ist ein bisschen
missverständlich man würde jetzt decken
also in der idealen natur wenn man sitzt
man umgangssprachlich versteht
da kann doch das böse gar nicht drin
liegen im idealen kann das böse nicht
liegen aber bleibt es versteht es ebenso
der sagt es ist eben die logische natur
das ist die also eher im sinne der idee
das ist die idee die gott von seinem
geschöpf haben muss aufgrund seiner
logik nicht als zwang als wesens
notwendigkeit ideale natur meint hier
ist eben die logische natur eher logisch
hier in ideal einsetzen nicht im sinne
des besten also logische natur des
geschäfts und die logische natur des
geschäfts sagt es muss endlich sein und
dann wie sie richtig sagen haben wir
eine verbindung zu den zumal und
metaphysik um hass ich würde das jetzt
auch mal vorschlagen
und es ist richtig sagte computer welche
der folgenden thesen vertritt kann das
absolut böse ist nur der böse wille böse
können eigentlich nur maximen genannt
werden sie der mensch kann ich das aus
eigener kraft das gute wählen die der
mensch hat einen hang zum bösen
[Musik]
jetzt spüre ich bin jetzt aber auch
nicht mehr ganz sicher mit einer frage
darüber müssen wir noch diskutieren kurz
ja gibt es ergänzungen problematisierung
das ist die frage was ist das verhältnis
von wille und maxime sie kennen
vielleicht dieses zitat bekannt dass
kann sagt gut ist allein ein guter wille
sagt in seiner schrift über die
grundlegung zum mittag das hinten also
nicht die handlung ist gut eigentlich
sind eigentlich ist nur der wille gut
die motivation und der wille ist
verkannt immer auch letztendlich die
maxime oder die die einheit der maximen
könnte man jetzt kann man es umdrehen
und sagen absolut nicht gut seien
absolut böse ist nur der böse will und
maximen sind ja auch wesentlich
strukturiert als wäre das genau dasselbe
dieselbe aussage ich hatte noch mich
gefragt wie es denn mit 10c der mensch
kann nicht aus eigener kraft das gute
wählen wenn das jetzt kann vertreten
würde wäre er also ganz stark im sinne
von luther wenn er es nicht vertreten
würde diese these
dann würde er sich den vorwurf des
plagiats muss ein handeln wie stehen sie
dazu
wir hatten da auch im seminar kurz
darüber diskutierten der zusammenfassung
warmen wir auch kurz darauf eingegangen
jetzt kann ein plagiat anzufragen
also ich kann schon mal vorweg nehmen
wäre nicht richtig also anzukreuzen nach
kant können wir so was wie eine
revolution unserer gesinnung erreichen
wir können uns selbst revolutionieren
dazu brauchen wir vielleicht auch ein
bisschen die hilfe anderer
aber es ist irgendwie auch möglich aber
wie kann man jetzt kann dennoch gegen
den vorwurf des plagiats muss
verteidigen
also wenn man sagt erkannt indem du es
für möglich erachtet dass wir aus
eigener kraft zum guten uns entscheiden
können brauchen wir doch nicht nur die
hilfe gottes
damit ist aber bella diana das könnte
man jetzt sagen wie kann man jetzt kann
verteidigen dagegen
das geht so ein bisschen die richtung
wie du es jetzt über luther gesagt hat
das scheint mir da könnte sagen ja
markant können wir uns nie sicher sein
ob wir wirklich das gute jetzt werden
wir tauschen uns ständig doch nach kant
als gigantische philosophie kann man
eigentlich auch so lesen das ist eine
reine lehre des scheins ist kant möchte
letztendlich uns und seiner philosophie
vom schein von der täuschung befreien
die vernunft nach kant täuscht uns
ständig sowohl in der theoretischen
hinsicht als auch in der praktischen der
theoretischen erkannt dass die dialektik
trans zentrale dialektik ist die logik
des scheins die vernunft sagt kann
täuscht uns vor dass es so was gäbe wie
eine seele als wirkliches ding die
unsterblichkeit der seele
das ist eine reine in der phantasie idee
der vernunft und genauso könnte man
sagen
täuschen wir uns auch in moralischer
hinsicht wenn es darum geht das gute zu
bestimmen wir können uns nach kann nie
sicher sein ob wir tatsächlich jetzt
gute motive in uns haben
und das könnte man jetzt dagegen
anbringen könnte sagen kann ist kein
plagiat
obwohl er ist für möglich erachtet dass
wir prinzipien und zum aus fragen der
freiheit zum guten entscheiden weil wir
uns nie sicher sein können ob wir nicht
doch wenn wir glauben dass böses von zu
haben uns da enttäuschen es könnte immer
sein
deswegen würde ich das mal vorschlagen
das ist richtig letzte frage welche der
folgenden thesen vertritt schelling aber
das böse ist eine privat ion b das böse
ist nicht durch unvollkommenheit
angemessen charakterisiert sie das böse
hat ein wesen die das böse ist mit der
central kraft zu vergleichen
meldungen sind erwünscht sind bekommen
was sagen sie gehen wir einfach durch
risiken daraus ist das böse nach
stellingen eine privat nicht genau
jennings der stärkste denke der
perversion szene vor kirche gold den wir
heute noch ausführlicher behandelt
werden wie sieht es damit aus dass das
böse nach schilling nicht durch
unvollkommenheit angemessen
charakterisiert sie nie kennen ja das
böse ist durchaus irgendwie vollkommen
zu nennen nach schilling sie das böse
hat ein wesen
würden sie sagen
in schillingen vertreter der perversion
theorie ist dann ihr gehabt und hat das
böse sein eigenes substanz die das böse
ist mit der central kraft zu vergleichen
ja das war jetzt eine fiese frage
ja zentrifugalen als aus dem zentrum
streben und zentral wäre ja ins zentrum
hinein streben in der physik wissen sie
ja ist es ja letztlich dasselbe zentral
und zentrifuge sind glaube ich nur zwei
aspekte der selbst sache aktion gleich
reaktionen
aber hier ist es wäre so nach shell wäre
das böse eben gerade darin versuchen aus
dem zentrum zu weich und nicht ins
zentrum hinein zu streben
halte das ist praktisch wäre falsch und
das war richtig und damit haben wir wie
sie jetzt gleich in der auflösung sehen
wir haben wirklich 170 470 punkten wir
haben eine genauigkeit von 100 prozent
im ersten versuch das schätzen den start
jetzt gehen wir weiter jetzt kommen wir
endlich zur kirche gehen und da haben
wir jetzt uns seine schrift mit dem
titel die krankheit zum tode vorgesetzt
und diese schrift wird häufig verglichen
mit hegels phänomenologie des geistes
da wir jetzt nicht das referat hören sag
ich was und du dann gerne auch wieder
also gregor hat eben und das bringt uns
jetzt wieder zurück zur letzten sitzung
er hat in berlin als kicker kommt aus
dänemark und hat aber in berlin dann
schelling gehört schelling den wir den
letzten sitzung behandelt haben und er
war am anfang von schelling begeistert
als schelling das wort existenz im
begriff die existenz verwendet hat also
kicker hat vor allem hegel vorgeworfen
der ja auch in berlin zieht oberland war
die ganze existenz allein ins logische
zu verlagern als existenz nur als eine
logische kategorie zu fassen
kicker ist darum zu tun die mögliche
existenz zu fassen
naja also im sinne die wirklich dieses
existenzialismus und er wirkt hegel vor
eben wirklich existenziell
existenzialistisch existenzielle momente
wie eben auch jetzt die sünde nur als
eine logische bestimmung zu verstehen
die aber uns selbst gar nicht richtig
betrifft und das ist einfach der
zusammenhang geologe die kategorien
folgen auseinander
er sagt über das hat mit meiner existenz
nichts zu tun
geo hat natürlich einen ganz klaren
protestantischen hintergrund den ersten
vorlesung von stelle sehr beeindruckt
als er gesagt hat schelling verwende den
begriff der existenz auf eine ganz
andere weise als das hegel tod war aber
nach der vierten oder fünften vorlesung
total enttäuscht und hat sich sehr
negativ über stellen geäußert weil er
das nicht bei ihm gefunden hat was er
sich erhofft hatte peter weißt du noch
anderes super kicker
der letzte seiner art die zentralen
aussagen können
die drogen waren
das internet
universitäts
die großen unterschiede
hier und kennt ihr das
überhaupt nicht
über abgewinnen könnte allerdings unter
prekärer
war es nicht ganz große vermögen und
einkommen
eine philosophische spitze
sondern
war eigentlich
aussteigen
sehr sehr
ein sehr existenzielle in den dingen
also
mensch der anfang
glauben
stark abgeschnitten versicherung
antworten geschehen ist
das alt geworden
also ein
dieser befund
gab es betrieben das leben
die schriften das
in der tat werden im tieferen system
fielen
denn sie tragen das oft charakter der
vegetation und pflegen der besinnung auf
ein thema
in seinem leben aber auch an seinem
schreiben zum anlass
viele sind am geschichte ist nicht
überschreiten
das ist eben viel gewogen
draußen
münchen spielen
in seinem
kaiser
in der bucht
viel mehr war als die us regierung
viele haben auch mannschaft haben
sogenannte exit der dessen existenz sie
oft nach vorn denken propheten gesehen
derart zu schreiben an einem samstag
oder so das sind also mit der form des
torwarts der dichtung des romans besucht
und
die sozusagen lebens zu setzen
der auszudrücken es war alles
extra system figur machen also gleich
auch als eine in seinem gesamtwerk
erscheinen
diese hat ganz abgesehen
zu wenig
das völlig richtig gesagt er war kein
professioneller philosophie der theologe
er hat sich sogar immer gegen die
professionelle philosophie theologie
gewendet er hat seine ganzen welt immer
unter einem pseudonym geschrieben also
auch sein verständnis von autorschaft
ist versteht ist verändert und er hat
eben auch sehr viel kritik an dem
zeitgenössischen christentum geübt eben
dass es für bürgerlich zeit dass
erstarrt sei letztendlich ist das so ein
lutherischer impetus in ihm vielleicht
noch drin so was ein protestantisches
der damals noch ihre schwächen haben
aufgrund des starts bedeckt ist
das ist erstens
und er kommt aus einem kind aus als
erwartet
kirchen und beamten
geistlicher positiven test an tischen
aber in genau sich das problem aber
insofern eigentlich eine lieblingsserie
oder soldaten veröffentlicht ist also
keine schritte für deutsche spieler
reise machen und damit zu stehen dass es
gegen wirklich an den kragen gegangen
wären anders mit aussagen möglich
also selbst hätten
denn erscheinungsform das beste seiner
zeit an der versuch ein bisschen
die selbst zurück
also es war christliche diesen
kirchlichen funktionen frei zu nehmen
und damit das bürgerliche gewissen zu
seiner zeit geschlagen
das letzte
zunächst das
seine anfang an zurück ins geschäft für
besonderes
bis 20
also ganz guten namen die karte war
diese summe hatte und wegen der
dialektische theologie ist es die
stärkste technologische steuerung ist
und 20
das tue ich
kommt auch ins geschäft vor
vor der begriff des dialektischen davon
legen hat aber nur versteht und neun
verwendet
die gedanken der menschen zutiefst
sünderin
zutiefst meine kenntnisse seine
fähigkeit begrenzt ist aussagen über
gott
angemessen sind alles
da habe ich keineswegs so dass
bekannt wurde er als kristall
in der zeit als dieser art zu denken
sicherheit sagen
prof
die deutsche sap
die organisation
auch heiliger hat natürlich city von
geklaut kann man schon fast sagen also
zitiert ihn nicht immer da wo er sich
auf ihnen bezieht muss man schon sagen
aber er hat natürlich sehr und logisch
sehr philosophisch weiter gedacht also
ein ganz wichtiger denker der war eben
auch in einer wichtigen beziehung steht
zur klassischen deutschen philosophie zu
schelling und zwei hebel vor allem und
da jetzt eigentlich hatten aber dafür
schelling wollen wir jetzt einfach in
die auf die leitfragen übergehen und
immer auch den schelling vor augen
behalten als ein hintergrund vor dem
sich dann kicker abgibt und die erste
frage die wir uns stellen wollen ist die
worin nach kicker der unterschied
zwischen der philosophischen und
theologischen bestimmung der sünde
besteht das ist vielleicht die
wichtigste frage wann erscheint
wir werden diese behandlung am falle
seiner kritik an sokrates ziehen als er
sagt sokrates ist der inbegriff der
philosophischen bestimmung der sünde so
wie es sogar dass das böse oder diese
stimmt und ich letztendlich oder
religionen christentum wir auch immer
letztendlich die eigentlich oder die
überzeugendste bestimmung das sind also
die philosophie sagte kieker
kann eigentlich wenn sie sich als zog in
der sokratischen tradition stehend
versteht nicht die sünde angemessen
verstehen hier kommt jetzt also ganz
stark diese theologische dimension
spielen dann unter welchen
gesichtspunkten kritisierte er die
sokratische theorie des hundes habe ich
jetzt schon ein bisschen vorweggenommen
dann kann man sich fragen ob eine
private wird eine pervasive theorie des
bösen vertritt und dann auch als
vorgriff auf paul tillich gehen wir den
nächsten sitzung haben was kennt seinen
dämonischen mensch nach kirche kommt das
ist auch noch spannend
jetzt legt man einfach mal los und jetzt
sehen sie gleich die am ersten zitat das
er in einer sehr großen nähe zu
schelling steht er sagt der mensch ist
geist was aber ist geist der geist ist
dass selbst was aber ist dass selbst das
selbst ein verhältnismäßig zu sich
selbst verhält oder ist dasjenige am
verhältnis dass das verhältnis ich zu
sich selbst verhält dass selbst ist
nicht das verhältnis sondern dass das
verhältnis zu sich selbst fällt der
mensch ist eine synthese von
unendlichkeit und endlichkeit von
zeitlichen und ewigen und freiheit und
notwendigkeit kurz eine synthese also
geister kann auch schon bei schelling
vor
jetzt müssen wir das mal irgend ein
bisschen veranschaulichen ein verhältnis
das sich zu sich selbst verhält
machen wir das jetzt als ich hatte mir
das überlegt hatte sich selbst verhalten
wenn jetzt das ist in der form einer
logischen relation und zu überlegen ist
cricket verhält sich das was ich selbst
er ist die relation
also ein reflexivität kriegen verhält
sich steht eine relation selbstbezug wie
auch immer zu art
ja das könnte man vielleicht noch hier
eher noch mehr selbstbewusst oder so das
ist jetzt ebenfalls mal eine eines
selbst beziehung
natürlich kann man sich jetzt noch
fragen wie sieht es aus mit dieser
synthese ist jeder sich an schelling wo
es darum ging auch das selbst zu
bestimmen und bei schelling war es so
schelling sagte dass der geist oder die
gewinne individuelle persönlichkeit kann
man ja auch so nachdem machen ist
letztendlich eine synthese aus eicken
wille und universal will
das ist die synthese sagt jenny und ganz
ähnlich scheint es mir hier zu sein also
die endlichkeit die zeitlichkeit die
wäre nach schelling alles auf dieser
seite der eigene wille unserer des
wortes beschränktheit und das hier ist
die unendlichkeit universalbank hat das
ist ganz ähnlich wie bei schelling wie
dieses selbst gerichtet ist auf zwei
entgegengesetzten prinzipien könnte man
sagen dass entscheidend ist jetzt dass
das schelling die eigentlich aufhören
also verschenkt genügt das netz
ermöglicht zur bestimmung des geistes
und verkehr geworden nicht das
entscheidende tor sagt das ist nicht
genug
ich setze jetzt hier einfach mal noch
mal ein
die unendlichkeit das wäre jetzt
nachgekommen unendlichkeit
neviges und hier eben endlichkeit und
zeitliches und dann haben wir hier noch
freiheit das ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig freiheit und notwendigkeit
aber da könnte man könnte hier
notwendigkeiten für freiheit ein stück
wobei natürlich der geist verstellen
immer frei ist so also so weit sind die
beiden jetzt eigentlich recht ähnlich
aber jetzt kommt die ganz entscheidende
änderung next zitat sagt ein solches
verhältnis der sich zu sich selbst hält
ein selbst muss entweder sich selbst
gesetzt haben oder durch etwas anderes
gesetz sein ist das verhältnis dass ich
zu sich selbst verhält durch etwas
anderes gesetzt so ist das verhältnis
zwar das dritte aber dieses verhältnis
das dritte ist dann doch wieder ein
verhältnis fällt sich zu dem ewigen
wovon das ganze verhältnis gesetzt
worden
also das dritte kann man sagen ist jetzt
also 12 31 23 es tritt vielleicht nicht
hundertprozentig
hier kommt jetzt noch was neues ins
spiel was kommt jetzt hier noch ein
spiel was muss ich jetzt in dieses
schema noch eintragen damit ich diesen
komplexen verhältnis in diesem zitat
gerecht werden kann
ja
das wäre das vierte dann also wir sind
schon am dritten genau das führte dann
mit sind ja wozu das jene zudem das
verhältnis das zu sehr feld wieder in
einem verhältnis steht das kann man
jetzt was was könnte das sein zb genau
also dass das selbst könnte er sich
selbst gesetzt haben
haben sie eine idee wenn er damit meinen
könnte dass das selbst sich selbst setzt
das ich sich selbst setzt das ist jetzt
ein zitat aus der philosophiegeschichte
vorsichtigem der fichte sagt dass ich
setze sich selbst das setzt sich auch
nicht durch und so weiter was genau es
mit diesen sätzen gemeint ist es ganz
schwierig geworden versteht es jetzt
offensichtlich und theologisch fichte
scheint es nicht unbedingt unter logisch
zu verstehen sondern ihr bewusstseins
theoretisch wie das selbstbewusstsein
sich konstituiert steht er da liest
jetzt sicht ziemlich unter logisch mit
diesen sätzen
also man könnte jetzt sagen können wie
normale relation und nehmen das jetzt
einfach mal nix also das ist jetzt das
selbst
und da steht eben wieder in ein
verhältnis zu etwas das selbst gesetzt
hat da könnte jetzt eben hier herein
fallen dann wäre das eine selbst
schöpfung aber das sagt aber das ist
unsinn selbst schöpfen das geht nicht
ja so ne also autobauers ist oder so
eine kreation excel oder wie könnte man
es nennen so eine selbst verursachen
das ist für kicker also unsinnig also
dieses wegs wäre dann eben zum beispiel
dann könnte man jetzt an einsätzen das
sagte jetzt nicht aber wichtig ist hier
eben dass schelling denken nur diese
sache hier für kirche dann muss hier
noch letztendlich bezug zu gott kommen
ist ganz wichtig
ohne diesen bezug ist es selbst nicht
hinreichend bestimmt also diese
transzendenz verkehr gehören auch ins
spiel kommen
und entscheidend ist dass die theorie
der sünde des bösen ganz wesentlich von
diesen zusätzlichen verhältnis lebt
schelling ist es nicht ganz extrem so
aber für schelling ist eigentlich das
böse etwas was ich hier zwischen diesen
zwei prinzipien letztendlich abspielt
setzt sich das universal über den
eigenwillig oder den eigenen über das
universal daran entscheidet sich ob
jetzt dann das selbst in seiner existenz
gut oder böse ist
es ist als eben eine frage ist bleibt in
diesem bereich
und dieser bereich wird völlig
ausgeklammert und verteidiger kommt
jetzt eben dieses zusätzliche verhältnis
mit dem spiel
und deswegen ändert sich auch die
auffassung der sünde weil eben hier
plötzlich die sünde nicht mehr nur als
ein verhältnis zu diesen
konstituierenden prinzipien gefasst wird
sondern immer noch im transzendenten
besuchen also die transzendenten
relation die immer noch für die
bestimmende mit einbezogen werden muss
das böse zeigt sich gerade an dem
verhältnis zu demjenigen wasser selbst
gesetzt hat also es wird wesentlich
komplexer es ist nochmal eine stufe
höher als es bei shell in bar
so könnte man es jedenfalls lesen ist
also noch mal höhere potenz
daran zeigt sich auch wie wir gleich
noch sehen werden dass das böse die
sünde kicker viel potenzierter ist altes
für schelling überhaupt denkbar ist wie
potenzierter jetzt bringt das gleich
durch die definition sünde ist vor gott
oder mit der vorstellung von gott
verzweifelt nicht man selbst sein zu
wollen oder verzweifelt man selbst sein
zu wollen
die sünde ist demnach potenzierter
schwäche oder potenzierter trotz der
sünde ist die potenzierung der
2 führung wir haben jetzt schon dieses
potenzierte als es eine höhere stufe das
müssen wir natürlich gerne was ist jetzt
verzweifelt überhaupt zur kirche kommen
verzweiflung
wir haben hier
also er ordnet hier kennt also zwei
arten der verzweiflung verzweifeln nicht
man selbst sein zu wollen oder
verzweifelt man selbst sein zu wollen
erste form der verzweiflung scheint die
verzweigung der schwäche zu sein also
nicht man selbst sein zu wollen
die zweite verzweiflung die verzweiflung
man selbst sein zu wollen ist der trotz
wenn ich es recht verstehen wie kann man
sich jetzt das vorstellen verzweifelt
nicht man selbst sein zu wollen
kennen sie das woran zeigt sich das wie
kann man verzweifelt nicht man selbst
sein wollen
die verzweiflung außen vor gelassen wie
kann man vor gott nicht man selbst sein
wollen haben sie kennt jeder
ja das wäre eine möglichkeit
das wäre jetzt in wirklichkeit auf die
handlung bezogen
ja genau
genau ich glaube dass mein tier mainz
noch stärker auf die existenz bezogen
also ich möchte nicht ich selbst sein
ich bin mir selbst unzufrieden
warum bin ich so wie ich bin mit mir
nicht zufrieden ich möchte nicht ich
selbst sein
möchte jemand anderes sein möchte ich
nicht sein wenn ich es recht verstößt
die schwäche und wie kann man jetzt man
selbst sein wollen verstehen sie das
verzweifelt man selbst sein zu wollen
vor gott jetzt wieder eine idee wie kann
man das sein wollen
denken sie mal an prometheus diese
prometheus diese geschichte von
prometheus
also
dass man zb also ich denke jetzt an
folgendes dass man zum beispiel dass man
sich ertragen kann das man geben
abhängig ist als geschöpf ich möchte
also herr mahler selbst seien diese
ganze autonomie gedanken dass wir zwei
wird man selbst sein zu wollen ist
glaube ich nach ticker dieser fall wo
man es nicht erträgt ein geschöpf zu
sein um als der herr seiner selbst dann
möchte man möchte sich selbst
konstituieren merkt aber dass es eben
immer gott gibt von dem mann abhängig
ist und den man als eine einschränkung
des eigenen selbst empfindet zu würdigen
wissen das hat was von prometheus und
gerade das jetzt hier also ist nicht zu
ertragen dass man abhängig ist
das nennt er jetzt den trotz und daran
sehen wir jetzt mal der trotz wird jetzt
uns noch weiter beschäftigen
man müsse jetzt noch kurz auf den
begriff der verzweiflung eingehen was
ist jetzt verzweiflung hatte jetzt hier
nicht genau erklärt was denken sie ist
jetzt verzweiflung
oder mal grundsätzlich allgemein gesagt
was ist verzweiflung eigentlich
ja möglichkeiten überzeugen
also eine ausweglosigkeit eine
verstrickung und das meinte damit also
kicker und das ist jetzt dieser begriff
der dialektik den du auch erwähnt hatte
von hegel herkommend für kinder ist die
gesamte existenz dialektisch also wir
verstecken uns ständig in abhängigkeiten
aus dem wir nicht rauskommen wenn wir
nicht wirklich uns auf ein ganz ohne
kenntnis punkt setzen also solange wir
hier in diesen problemen befangen sind
man selbst sein zu wollen nicht man
selbst sein zu wollen sind wir unrettbar
dialektisch verstrickt wir kommen da
nicht raus und zwar deswegen weil wir
unser gutes verhältnis nicht geklärt
haben
wir bleiben immer in uns drin und wie
wir es drehen und wenden wie kommen zu
keinem punkt damit hängt auch zusammen
das verzweifelt man selbst sein zu
wollen und nicht selbst sein zu wollen
eigentlich ganz eng miteinander verwandt
alles geben dann darüber und diese
verstrickungen die man nicht durchschaut
aus dem man selbst nicht herauskommt die
nennt kurz gesagt verzweiflung
es geht darum dass das selbst sich los
macht von gott nur in seiner eigenen
struktur bleibt und sich darin
verstrickt und letztendlich unrettbar
verstrickt das könnte man verzweiflung
die du hast du noch eine ergänzung was
schwebt ihr noch vor theologisch
verzweiflung
[Musik]
besonders nachhaltiges existenziell
verständigt weil es war einfach
natürlich auch
griffin des zweifels hinunter auf das
religiösen zweitens also ganz weit oben
erst zum 1
zweiter zweifel in zwei richtungen
einigen 2
sich selbst und zwei versenkbaren aber
ein gutes verhältnis
der zweite ganz aufzugeben oder zweifel
selbst eine ganz alltäglichen dingen
zeigt zweifel das vertrauen der offen
und so weiter
die ausrichtung
nicht so gut lief des religiösen
menschen den unsicherheiten
das sind
dazu
das begräbnis soll den deckel den für
dienstag
es sind missverhältnisse in denen wir
uns verschiedene den wir uns nicht mehr
von uns selbst heraus befreien können
verstrickungen die uns immer weiter in
einen strudel hinab gleiten lassen sonst
so vielleicht auch als ich denke
verstrickungen die eben immer was mit
dieser transzendenz zu tun haben das ist
verzweiflung und sieht man weiter das
aber ist oft genug übersehen worden dass
der gegensatz zur sünde keineswegs die
tugend ist dass sie das heißt eine zum
teil heidnische anschauung die sich mit
einem rein menschlichen maßstab gibt
rein menschlichen maßstab wieder jetzt
hier so zu verstehen dass wir uns nur
auf dieses verhältnis beziehen was das
selbst konstituiert das wäre in relation
zu art wurde nach schelling nur diesen
kreis hier das ist wieder der vorwurf
schelling die ganzen anderen die
vernachlässigung diesen transzendenz
bezug der konstitutiv ist das
entscheidende break tätige diese
transzendenten sie sind irgendwie
perspektive oder so eine idee nach kant
sein postulat oder was auch immer
können diese transzendenz relation ist
konstitutiv des selbst ist konstitutiv
wir können das ganze nicht denken wenn
du nicht hier noch eine klärung machen
so eine große klappe das ist es selbst
darin spielt das selbst haben und nicht
nur darin
wir brauchen ihn noch diesen bezug das
ist also ganz wichtig dass
zusammenzuspannen und deswegen wird eben
auch die sünde viel komplexeren holt ist
noch was sagen also deswegen ist eben
auch das gegenteil zur sünde
er sagt jetzt tägiger nicht die tugend
weil wenn die tugend des gegenteils der
sünde wäre wären wir nur in diesen moral
philosophischen kontexte moral
philosophische kontext ist letztendlich
kann man sagen dass hier
das ist moralität das wäre doppelt oder
auch
das böse und das ganze hier so bis dahin
das ganze hier
das ist dann eben erst die existenz in
der es eben auch die sünde gibt
wieder dieser bezug hier
er kann jetzt natürlich sagen bei
schelling hier in dem universal will den
ewigen ist dort schon drin kann man
sagen aber es ist ja hier nun also ich
sagen ist es hier immer es wird nicht
greifbar das universale ist nicht eine
person oder ein ein subjekt geben dass
man sich verhält wenn man hier böse nach
schelling handelt geht es immer um eine
ordnung bestehen der handeln wir nicht
gegen den universal bin als solchen
sondern wir ordnen universal wählen und
sagen will und das ist wie bei kant wir
handeln aber nie gegen den universalen
als solche jetzt in diesem augustin
ischen modell das im trotz modell und
kann sagt selbst eine böse vernunft das
böse um des bösen willen zu tun das geht
nichts erkannt und ich glaube dieses
modell bleibt knackig und bleibt
schelling drin und hergegangen möchte
dass gerade ihm möchte dieses augustin
ische modell dieses prinzip stahls und
denken können ich glaube dass das
entscheidende jetzt sagt er eben hier
die gegensatz zur sünde ist nicht die
tugend ist der glaube und der glaube
wäre eben gerade hier
diese relation dass es entscheidend hier
in dieser relation zu diesem mix in
unserem selbst verhältnis uns zu diese
nix zu verhalten wenn ich also zu gott
zu verhalten daran zeigt sich ob wir
entdecken der existenzform der sünde
oder des glaubens sind und ich habe die
moralische oder unmoralisch sind
das ist nur eine frage die diese selbst
relation mit betrifft in diesem sinne
das kann tische modell des kanton ist es
schwierig die ganze philosophie macht
sich nur hier über gedanken diese eine
entscheidende dimension
die ist völlig außer form außen
vorgelassen worden dass nur menschlicher
menschlicher maßstab das ist heidnisch
das ist völlig ungenügend hatte glauben
also der glaube wäre dann eben das
verhältnis zu diesen mix was das
selbstbildnis gesetzt hat der eben jetzt
endlich das gute oder das richtige dass
das anlass angemessen ausdrückt also ein
positives ein gelungenes verhältnis die
sünde ist das missverhältnis in diesem
höheren verhältnis sagt dass sünde ist
jetzt definiert es vor gott verzweifelt
man selbst sein zu wollen
also vorjahr 2 wird nicht man selbst
sein zu wollen oder fagott war zwar wird
man selbst sein zu wollen
also diese zwei formen die wir im
vorletzten zitat hatten hier
schwäche patentierte schwäche oder den
potenzierte trotz vorkommt
es gibt also zwei formen der sünde und
jetzt bringt er dagegen den glauben
glaube ist dass das selbst in dem es
selbst er selbst ist in dem es er selbst
sein will
durchsichtig ihm gott gründet also hier
diese relation ganz klar vor augen hat
und nicht nur ästhetisch vor augen hat
sondern existenziell sich selbst als
sich in dieses verhältnis begibt dieses
verhältnis eintritt könnte und zwar das
wäre dann der glaube
und es ist natürlich etwas völlig
anderes als die moral als unmoralische
handlung und moralischen maxime
das ist ja klar durchsichtig ihn gut
gründe also diese verhältnisse aufklärt
und jetzt kommt hier das interessante
nämlich die sokratische definition da
sitzen wie mir scheint der präsident der
entscheidende punkt hier jetzt zeigt
nämlich sünde ist unwissenheit das ist
bekannt die sokratische definition das
missliche bei der sokratischen
definition ist nun der sie es unbestimmt
ist wie die unwissenheit selbst näher zu
verstehen ist
die ursprung und so weiter das heißt
selbst wenn die sünde unwissenheit ist
oder das was das christentum vielleicht
ihr dummheiten würde was sich in einer
hinsicht gar nicht leugnen lässt handelt
es sich dann um eine ursprüngliche
unwissenheit also um einen zustand von
jemandem der von der wahrheit nichts
gewusst hat und bisher nichts hat wissen
können oder ist es eine erzeugte eine
spätere unwissenheit hier muss man jetzt
noch erwähnen dass kirche hier die
platonischen sokratis vor augen hat sie
kennen vielleicht ein paar stellen da
gibt es aus dem aus dem pro tag und aus
dem georgier es gibt stellen als
platonische dialoge wo der sokrates wir
tun niemals sehenden auges das böse das
böse ist immer nur entsteht immer nur
aus unwissenheit oder aus falscher
erkenntnis
frage an sie was ist das problem wenn
bei sokrates nehmen wir sagen das böse
das man kurz aus hier also so carter
sagt
größe sind gleich unwissenheit oder
sogar viele fehler der erkenntnis
was ist das problem das böse so zu
bestimmen
würden sie typische fälle des bösen so
bestimmen dass da eben eine person sich
halt geirrt hat alte bankräuber die
bankräuberin hatte sich einfach nur
gehört das problem ist wie könnte auch
sagen wenn die person sich jetzt nur
geirrt hat dann ist sie vielleicht
einfach nicht so intelligent das heißt
der grund des bösen wirklich ihrer
dummheit also in ihre mangelnde
intelligenz und verdiente lizenz kann
die person nichts also ist sie gar nicht
schuldig dafür das problem ist wenn wir
so eine theorie ansätzen sind wir ihm
bösen eigentlich immer nur sehr begrenzt
schuldig man ist die dummheit
man könnte natürlich sagen die person
ist selbst schuld dass es so dummes sie
hätte dafür sorge tragen müssen dass sie
klüger ist kann man sich aber wieder
fragen warum hat sie da nicht sorge
dafür getragen dass sie klüger ist kann
sich dieselbe frage ist siegerin ist
kommt dann in regress zu tun wenn sie zu
tun war dann war das nicht um high
zweiter stufe für diese wieder zu
rechnen war wäre und so weiter und so
fort es gibt kein ende sagen also das
recht es muss was im will und sein
assistent wedelt mit dem willen zu tun
haben
also das ist so kroatische modell das
ist die 5
das ein riesenproblem zug hat es ist so
ein sogenannter intellektuell ist eine
intellektuelle tische theorie des bösen
das böse
aus mangel an vernunft letztendlich eine
privat ions theorie ist also ein
bisschen im hintergrund des chemischen
produktions- theorie
sie ist einmal weiter ist die
unwissenheit dass letztere so muss die
sünde ja eigentlich etwas anderem als in
der unwissenheit stecken
sie muss in derjenigen aktivität des
menschen stecken mit der er daran
gearbeitet hat seine erkenntnis zu
verdunkeln
aber auch wenn man das an dem zug hat
diese hartnäckige und crc liebe
gemütlichkeit wieder in dem die frage
nun nämlich lautet ob sich denen der
menschen die im augenblick also damit
begann seine erkenntnisse verbunden
dessen deutlich bewusst ist ist er es
nicht so ist die erkenntnis ja schon um
einiges verdunkelt die er damit begann
und die frage klärt nur noch einmal
wieder nimmt man dagegen an dass er sich
als er seine erkenntnis zu verdunkeln
begann dessen deutlich bewusst ist so
liegt die sünde ja wenn sie auch
unwissenheit ist insofern die letztere
das ergebnis ist nicht in der erkenntnis
sondern im willen und die frage die sich
stellen müsste ist die nach dem
verhältnis von erkenntnis und villen
zueinander auf alles derartig und hier
könnte man nun viele tage weiter fragen
lässt sich diese grafisch definition
eigentlich nicht ein
können sie noch einmal kurz in algen
worden wieder geben wo jetzt das problem
liegt nachgegangen
genau der villen spirit kommt ins spiel
und das ist auch wenn man mal die
geschichte der philosophie schaut etwas
was eigentlich erst mit augustinus
beginnen augustinus gilt zum beispiel
nach hannah arendt als der erfinder oder
entdecker des modernen willens begriffs
den modernen willens begriff gibt es in
der antiken philosophie so noch nicht es
gibt bei aristoteles die pro es ist also
die wahl
es gibt bei platon in der politik ein
seiner politik gibt es verschiedene
seelen teile von dem man personen derart
will es sind das begehren familien mögen
das epigenetik und sowas aber das ist
nicht der wille der sich entscheiden
kann aus freiheit also mit augustinus
beginnt eigentlich erst die moderne
willens theorien augustin das ist nicht
ohne grund theologisch also es ist doch
spannend dass diese über die
existenzielle anti intellektualismus
entscheidungs theorie zum guten zum
bösen biologische wurzeln hat das
schreiben jetzt schon sehr zentral zu
sein dass die philosophie philosophische
antike tradition hat das problem dass
sie den willen gegen der vernunft
gegenüber der fünf zu schwach ansetzt
und dann haben wir das problem dass wir
die individuelle existenz die
individuelle entscheidung zum bösen
nicht mehr richtig fassen können weil
das ganze nur noch privat ions
theoretisch verstanden werden kann
man könnte also sagen die tatsache dass
man die das böse präventions-
theoretisch denken kann verdankt sich
letztendlich einem ganz starken
christlichen impetus dieser williamson
begriff der von augustinus ins spiel
kommt da hat die intellektuell ist ische
antike philosophie große problem indem
sie die vernunft über den willen setzt
ich denke da ist was dran ist was dran
so hat das kommt deshalb eigentlich
nicht zur bestimmung sünde hast bei
einer definition der sünde misslich sein
dürfte
wieso das ist nämlich die sünde
unwissenheit so existiert ja die sünde
eigentlich nicht denn die sünde ist ja
gerade bewusstheit bedeutet die sünde
dass man das richtige nicht kennt so
dass man deshalb das falsche tut sie
existiert diese nicht ist das des
zünders und nimmt man hier an was so
gerade das ebenfalls annahmen das ist
nämlich nicht vorkommen dass jemand der
das richtige weißes fall tot
oder dass jemand der weiß was das etwas
das falsche ist dieses falsche tut halt
so ist diese grabstätte nicht so richtig
so existiert die sünde gar nicht hier
haben wir jetzt den augustin ischen fall
dass jemand der weiß dass etwas das
falsch ist dieses falsche tut
augustinus er weiß es nicht nur das ist
das falsch ist und trotzdem soll er tut
es weil es das falsche ist also nicht
nur obwohl sondern weil die konjunktion
ist das entscheidende nicht trotz
sondern gerade weil er ist das falsch
ist und das kann eben sokrates und
seiner intellektuellen theorie nicht
erkennen nach klick go welche bestimmung
ist es also die sokratis bei der
definition der sünde fehlt es ist der
wille trotz und jetzt kommt eben dieser
trotzdem spielt die griechische
intellektualität war zu glücklich so
naiv zu ästhetisch zu ironisch witzig
zur sünde
als dass es ihren kopf er in den kopf
gewollt hätte jemand könne es
wissentlich unterlassen das gute zu tun
oder wissentlich mit dem wissen von dem
was richtig ist das falsche tun dass
griechen tun statuiert einen
intellektuellen kategorischen imperativ
peter hier kommt jetzt plötzlich das
ästhetischen spielen und das ist ja auch
bei kirche gottes weiß dass ich besser
als ich interessante opposition das
ästhetische und das ethische na das ist
ja ein riesenthema sicherlich auch in
der theologie wie man sich dazu
verhalten sein könnte man jetzt mal alle
teilnehmer fahren ist das problem des
ästhetischen das ästhetischen wenn das
gegen das ethische ausspielt kennen sie
diese schrift entweder oder vom caterer
also das ist kennen sie nicht das ist
letztendlich alles was sozusagen peter
oder soll ich es ein bisschen aus wie ja
also es ist letztendlich diese frage
welche existenz weise wir wählen wollen
wollen wir die ästhetiker sein also
immer dem schönen nachgeht oder wollen
wir der ethiker sein der den moralischen
maßstab anlegt und er sagt jetzt als und
das ästhetische ist für krieger immer
problematisch das ist nicht moralisch
oder nicht theologisch kluger sagt die
griechen waren einfach zu ästhetisch die
haben das ästhetische letztendlich über
alles gestellt ein schönes system gebaut
in dem alles vernünftig geordnet war
kosmos sagt er schon kosmos ist die
vernunft ordnung ist aber auch schmuck
oder kette da liegt es schon seit über
das führt an der wirklichen existenz
vorbei und nicht ohne
grund er sagte er ironisch er hat er
seine doktorarbeit wenn nicht alles
täuscht über den begriff der ironie
geschrieben
bei schläge oder so also hat sich damit
den roman mit der romantischen ironie
auseinandergesetzt und ironie hat zwar
auch was philosoph sokrates veronika
aber das zieht er jetzt sehr moralis
tisch nach also diese augustin ische
einsicht dass ich etwas tun kann weil es
böse ist und es auch gerade deswegen
wollen kann die kann diese griechische
intellektualismus nicht fassen
und da ist was dran ich denke es wäre
jetzt ungerecht alle philosophen
vorgegangen unter diesen
intellektualismus zu funktionieren es
gibt in der mittelalterlichen debatte
eine große diskussion darüber ob jetzt
der wille oder die vernunft ist
entscheidend ist was die handlung
konstruiert viele sagen es ist ein
wechselspiel zwischen familie bildung
vernunft und auch bei kant habe gesehen
dass der phänomene gibt die eben das
böse erklären die nicht nur in der
vernunft liegen oder sogar vielleicht
sogar anders ausgerückt einem zug der
vernunft bedeuten die selbst das böse
wollen kann wie dieses phänomen des
vernünftigen es ist zeit dass da wird er
der tradition nicht ganz gerecht aber so
ganz holzschnittartig macht den punkt
wie mir scheint wenn als ein mensch das
richtige nicht in derselben sekunde in
der es erkannt hat ausführt ja dann
kühlt zunächst einmal die erkenntnis ab
und so dann lautet die frage was hält
der wille von dem erkannt
der wille ist etwas dialektisches und
hat wiederum die gesamte niedere natur
im menschen unter sich
gefällt ihr nun das erkannte nicht dass
ergibt sich daraus zwar nicht dass der
wille hingeht und das gegenteil von dem
tun was die erkenntnis eingesehen hat
solche starken gegensätze kommen
wahrscheinlich ziemlich selten vor aber
der villa lässt dann einige zeit
vergehen es entsteht ein interim ein
inzwischen das heißt wir wollen es doch
bis morgen überlegen bei all dem wird
die erkenntnis dunkler und dunkler und
das nieder gewinnt mehr und mehr die
oberhand den acht das gute muss sofort
getan werden sofort wenn es erkannt ist
deshalb ist der rhein ideale der
übergang von dingen zum sein so leicht
dann geschieht hier geschieht alles
sofort das niedere dagegen hat seine
stärke im hinziehen
wir verdanken unsere erkenntnis will
endlich über diese zeitspanne klassen
zeit verstreichen und dadurch rückt das
gute uns in die ferne ist ein
interessanter ansatz aber er scheint
hier eben auch jetzt doch den augustinus
nicht ganz so klar zu sehen weil er sagt
solche starken gegensätze kommen
ziemlich selten vor wie sie kommen eben
doch vor zum beispiel bei augustinus
dass wir das gute sehen uns trotzdem ich
tun oder vielleicht sogar gerade
deswegen nicht tun weil es das gute ist
indem wir es wissen
allmählich hat er will nichts dagegen
dass das geschieht erdrückt fast ein
auge zu und wenn dann die erkenntnis
gehört verdunkelt ist dann verstehen
erkenntnis und will sich besser
schließlich sind sie ganz einer meinung
denn nun ist die erkenntnis zur zeit des
willens übergegangen und erkennt dass es
ganz richtig ist wie er es will woods
erlebt vielleicht eine große menge
menschen
sie arbeiten stück für stück daran ihr
ethisches und ethisch religiöses
erkennen zu verdunkeln
dass sie bis zur entscheidung und
konsequenzen führen will
die das niedere ihn nicht mag dagegen
erweitern sie ästhetisch und
metaphysische erkennen was in ethischer
hinsicht ablenkung bedeutet hier also
wieder eine kritik am esstisch
ästhetische ist nur eine ablenkung des
ästhetische baut uns schöne systeme
dessen bauten schöne ordnungen gibt uns
orientierung aber den wirklichen
existenz führt zur bei unsere wirkliche
existenzen kann das ästhetische nicht
treffen so hat es gibt die erklärung
wird das richtige nicht tue
der habe es auch nicht verstanden das
christentum holt jedoch ein bisschen
weiter aus das ist diese zusätzliche
relation das ist dieses weiter ausholen
hier dieser schwur hier heute etwas
weiter aus und sagte grund dafür dass er
es nicht verstehen wolle und dafür
wieder dass er ist das dass er das
richtige nicht wolle
und ferner lehrt ist dass ein mensch das
falsche tut der eigentliche trotz obwohl
er das richtige versteht oder dass er es
unterlässt das richtige zu tun
obwohl er ist versteht das ist hier
dieses obwohl ich glaube dass kicker
hier noch ein bisschen weitergehen
sollte und nicht nur dieses konzession
hier einfügen sollte sondern weil
weil also dass das ich glaube dieses mal
wäre in dieser kausalität noch stärker
im sinne von augustinus ich tue nicht
das gut nicht tun ich das böse obwohl
ich das gute einsätze gut ist es
natürlich schon ziemlich gut aber man
könnte eben sagen falls des diebstahls
ich tue das böse weil ich oder indem
wäre vielleicht sogar noch besser indem
dieses modelle in dem ich das gute so
jedenfalls kann man jetzt hier diese
konjunktion obwohl
verständlich machen die das antike
philosophen zum nicht erklären konnten
entkommen
und jetzt kommt eben schon mal der trotz
ins spiel also das falsche darf jetzt
nach gängiger nicht verstanden werden
als das böse die sinne darf nicht
verstanden werden als das falsche
das falsche wäre nun system ist das
defizit das falsche ist ein kreatives
phänomen kicker aber möglich dass
falsche in einen aktiven sinne verstehen
und sagt deswegen nicht also möchte das
böse die zu den aktiven sind wir
verstehen uns sagt deswegen nicht das
falsche
sondern sagt der trotz trotz fragen sie
zurück was ist denn der trotz
beschreiben sie mal kurz was kennen sie
phänomene die mit dem trotz in
verbindung hängen wann sind sie trotzig
vorher
genau man kennt das ja
genau richtig völlig richtig es geht
nicht um die sache es geht um
beziehungen und man kennt das denke vor
allem von kindern nämlich immer also
kinder sind besonders erwachsen
natürlich auch es gibt da ein buch das
der trotzkopf kennen sie das ein
kinderbuch der trotzkopf kinder können
besonders trotzig sein wie mir scheint
natürlich erwachsene auch dieses
deutsche roth trotz schutz und trutz
eine trutzburg denke auch dass es mit
dem trotzen als widerstand leisten erst
mal ganz klar dass sich entgegensetzen
aber sie haben glaube ich sehr gut diese
motive noch genannt die zu diesem trotz
führen
es ist es hat etwas damit zu tun dass
wir uns individualität behaupten voll
gegenüber anderen und es entgegen
gesetzt und uns das etwas verleiten
lassen was vielleicht nicht gerade gut
ist oder moralisch ist oder etwas
bewusst falsch machen ich mach das jetzt
bewusst falsch und das mache ich aus
einem trotz heraus das kennen sie ja
trotzdem kann man unterstellen dass er
genau weiß was er tut
das ist aber gerade deswegen tut weil
das war es und damit so etwas zu
kommunizieren und das ist eben gerade
nicht das falsche das falsche wäre da
könnte man sagt ja er wusste es halt
nicht oder sie wusste es halt nicht dass
nein er oder sie wusste es genau und
weil sie es wusste nennen wir es
trotzdem trotz zeigt sich dass man etwas
falsches böses tun indem man es
obwohl man es ist praktisch das
verhältnis zum falschen im trotz haben
wir hier ein selbstbewusstsein des
falschen und raffinieren das falsche und
wir unterliegen ihm nicht einfachen
unbewusst also trotz ist die bewusste
falschheit die selbstbewusste falschheit
die sich selbst setzen die falschheit
das wäre trotz glaube ich christlich
verstanden liegt die sünde als im willen
nicht in der erkenntnis und diese
verderbtheit des willens geht über das
bewusstsein dass einzelne hinaus das ist
die volle konsequenz denn sonst müsste
sich hinsichtlich dass einzelne die
frage geben wie die sünde begonnen haben
sünde ist nachdem man durch eine
offenbarung von gott darüber aufgeklärt
ist was sünde ist vor gott verzweifelt
nicht man selbst sein zu wollen wohl
verzweifelt man selbst sein zuvor
jetzt haben wir es all das ist jetzt
hier die ganz zentrale position ja jetzt
kommt hier die offenbarung ins spiel
was ist die offenbarung was denken sie
viele lange kämpfen
also man kann sagen moralische gesetze
oder man kann sagen das neue testament
alte testament die bibel könnte man
sagen
und was würde zu sagen als als theologe
was ist
dieses wissen
die haben und dann ist die frage
also man kann nichts sagen man hätte es
nicht gewusst die offenbarung ist eben
die bibel ist erhältlich ist bekannt
natürlich kann man sie jetzt wagen wie
verhält es sich mit menschen auf einem
anderen erdteil die noch nie was von der
bibel gehört haben das ist selig peter
ein ganz altes problem auch mit haben
taucher und sowas wie ist es mit
menschen die nicht getauft sind die
einfach nicht die umstände hatten ja
kommen die gleichen die hölle oder sowas
also diese fragen würde jetzt vielleicht
zu weit führen er hat das jetzt denke
ich nur bezogen auf seine lebenswelt
seine situation seine zeit und alle die
er da im blick hat die kennen die bibel
die wissen was drin steht
er richtet sich vielleicht auch sogar
nur gegen die protestanten dänemarks
kann durchaus sein also das ist ja auch
eine gewisse polemischen schrift die
vier kirchen kritik übt ganz im
protestantischen szene oder vielleicht
sogar im pietistischen sinne eine
innerkirchliche reformen die ja auch
anstrebt ne also durchaus realistische
züge immer könnte sie jetzt wohl schon
alle alle protestanten dänemarks über 16
jahre oder so es muss jetzt nicht
bezogen auf die ganze menschheit
unbedingt gelten aber natürlich hat
einen höheren anspruch
offenbarung also offensichtlich die
bibel
wir wissen es eigentlich und sünde
bedeutet das obwohl wir es wissen denn
noch eben in einem verzweifelten
verhältnis hier zu gott zu stehen das
ist die sünde
obwohl wir es ist obwohl es hätten
wissen können und jetzt kommt das dritte
kapitel und jetzt geht es um das
entscheidende dass die sünde keine
negation sollen eine position ist und
hier zeigt sich ganz deutlich dass
kinder keine privates theorie vertreten
wird es sein eine perversion zurück die
position ist natürlich auch verständlich
vor dem hintergrund des trotzes da wird
der trotz besonders wichtig nach der
aufgestellten definition der sünde
jedoch gehört zur sünde 1 durch die
vorstellung von gott unendlich
potenziert das selbst und so wiederum
die größtmögliche bewusstheit von der
sünde als handlung
das ist der ausdruck dafür dass die
sünde eine position ist dass sie vor
gott ist ist gerade das positive geben
ihr an ihr
glaube das zeigt nochmal hier schön
dieses hier also die sünde ist nicht
dann wird um die sünde ist nicht ein
fehler im erkennen sind sie ist die
höchstmögliche erkennt es überhaupt weil
wir uns in der sünde als wir selbst noch
mal in einem höheren verhältnis
gegenüber gott befinden deswegen ist die
sünde das größtmögliche bewusst sein was
wir haben weil es nicht nur einfach weil
wir darin nicht nur in einem verhältnis
stehen was sich zu uns selbst verhält
sondern indem wir uns dazu noch mal als
wir selbst etwas verhalten was uns
gesetzt das ist natürlich auch ein viel
höherer gerade an selbstbewusstsein weil
wir immer auf unserem grund reflektieren
und nicht nur auf uns selbst und
deswegen sagt wicker ist die sünde viel
viel potenzierter und viel positiver
wenn jetzt nicht im sinne des
moralischen natürlich aber im sinne des
gegenständlichen bewussten als es nur
ein fehler ist
christlich betrachtet ist die sünde
jedoch das muss geklappt werden
das ja das paradox ist dass kein mensch
begreifen kann eine position die aus
sich heraus eine mehr und mehr setzen
deponieren de kontinuierlich kite
entwickelt dann setzten polieren
also es ist so die sünde ist jetzt
nichts instanz eines einmaliges wir tun
jetzt mal hier die sünde und dann ist
wieder gut
das ist für kinder eine falsche
auffassung des bösen er möchte das böse
nicht so die sind nicht als etwas
einmaliges betrachten als etwas das
einmal passiert ist und dann passiert
wieder eine gute handlung von
verteidiger ist es so wenn wir einmal
merken dass wir was böse getan
böses getan haben dann ist das für
kinder ein anzeichen dass wir immer
schon der sünde waren die sünde ist
nichts was so hervorsticht
das sind die sünde ist er so eine
grundsituation und sünde ist auch nichts
statisches sagen was dynamisches als
etwas was uns jetzt etwas eigentlich
eine existenz im prinzip ist die sünde
hat was sehr lebendiges in die sind sehr
organisch gefasst verlieren das ist
vielleicht sogar paulus so ein bisschen
im hintergrund oder was meinst du die
sünde ist in einem anstoß angebot
paulus
das sind
waren fast schon gleich selbst also
siebte ist der zustand entwicklung von
waren stattfindet warum es den zustand
der jugendsünde sich realisieren das
sind eben keine fehltritte des desktops
erkenntnis als die eigene zu entdecken
als die eigene sind
was uns zur verfügung steht es mit der
hand zu bekommen
das ist nicht zu sagen wenn die eigenen
kinder allein zu stemmen können
den mann nicht wehtut und bot dem man da
erlangt oder berwert abstoßen kann
sondern wir das wesen des menschen
dem wurde
keine sind
ein begriff der in seinem post klaps
arischen zustand war schon gibt es in
sich
genau da brauch ich glaube da doch auch
seine polemische sich darin dass eben
die die gesetze wenn man auf die zehn
gebote bezieht eben uns letztendlich
immer nur zeigen dass wir sünder sind
also dass die sind ja auch aufbahrung
ich meine mutter muss sich aufbauen ist
ja
[Musik]
als er eigentlich nur negativ also gott
wird nicht für uns letztendlich
in der selbsterkenntnis vielleicht auch
gottes erkenntnis über die eigenen
sünden erkenntnis und es ist natürlich
glaube ich schon uhr protestantischer
gedanke so ein bisschen gibt es durch
paulus auch aber dieses eben sich immer
selbst wieder prüfen müssen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen gegen diese
applus geschichte dabei luther dass man
eben doch die sünde stärker betont oder
dieses österliche ereignis das man eben
die letztendlich osze wie du ja mal sagt
ist vom karfreitag her betrachtet in
dieser protestantischen tradition nicht
so sehr von der auferstehung das zeigt
sich also krieger als veritabler
protestanten
den start machen wenn man
aber sagen
eine kreuzigung stadt zu befreien man
macht dieses super tragen des kreuzes
selbst als 120 kandidaten vertreten ist
es am stärksten
man kann nur sagen oder
passt gerade alles nicht investiert sind
alles dinge die nicht so gepasst sind
ist nicht einer hat uns nicht einen tat
ist
die sitzungen des menschen
oder auch dieses johannes evangelium
wird wo ja auch jesus als der könig am
kreuz in seinem leiden
geschildert wird wo als auch das
negative mit dem höchsten in verbindung
gesetzt wird das würde kicker sicherlich
auch als das dialektische bezeichnet
diese die elektrische theologische
position und das gesetz für das wachsen
diese kontinuität ist ebenfalls ein
anderes als dasjenige für das wachsen
einer schuldsumme oder eine negation den
schulden wachsen nicht weil sie nicht
bezahlt werden sie wachsen jedes mal
wenn sie vermehrt werden die sünde
jedoch wächst mit jedem augenblick in
dem man sich nicht von ihr trennt der
sünder ist so weit wie möglich davon
entfernt recht zu haben wenn er nur jede
neue sünde heranwachsender sünde hält so
weit dass christlich betrachtete zustand
in der sünde eine größere sünde ist die
neue sünde ist
da muss man vielleicht hier in als
reinsetzen aber
oder passt auch die neue sind ich habe
verstehen sie jetzt das wie passt das
jetzt mit diesen schulden zusammen
wachsen die schulden trotz auch wenn man
sie nicht bezahlt meint die die die
zinsen und so die werden doch auffällig
wenn man die schulden nicht bezahlen
ich denke denke ich an zinsen und zone
natürlich wachsen die schulden wenn man
sie nicht bezahlt die wachsen die zinsen
zahlen und wachsen die schulden aber ich
glaube denke ich an die zinsen das war
nicht gerade ein bisschen mehr also wer
da geht wohl davon aus wenig schulden
habe ich schulde jetzt jemanden anderen
zehn euro ja dann wachsen sie nicht wenn
ich sie nicht zahlen
dann zahle ich sie im halben jahr er
denke jetzt nicht wie der moderne
europäer schulden im milliarden
milliarden
größe ja weil da wachsen die schulden in
jedem moment wo sie nicht bezahlt werden
und zwar extrem wegen des rund
zinssatzes dagegen von einer sehr
geringen schuld aus die sich nicht sind
es mäßig potenzierte
diese
und genau richtig und schulden sind
nicht objektiv dieser gegenstand der der
uns vorn steht sind ist das relationale
es geht immer in unserem verhältnis zum
zu diesem gegenstand und solange wir uns
in diesen verhältnissen wird die schuld
potenziert also hier ist wieder alles
relational gedacht bei kiki dollar
schulden nicht objektiv als ein
gegenstand die sünde sind als ein
subjekt sind über subjektivierung
sehr stark von sogenannten tags ende zu
unterschreiben das ist nicht ohne
die einhellige meinung es gibt auch
durchaus anders zu sehen
kann es starke kritisiert
er ist auf jeden fall
überhaupt ist eine region
die einzelnen taten sünden zu halten
also die vertretungen ein tag zu einer
sünde zu erklären
und dieses mädchen
dass die summe aller resultat zu
betrachten was ist in seiner clique auch
heißen kann man kann sünde vermieten
also ein mensch durch in kindergärten
sind und haben von bringen so ein team
stellen immer wieder schön
alle
also einen koffer mit sich rum
nämlich sind kinder besonders wichtig
sind verbrecher sind von dieser der ganz
massiv weg
die taten die beamten ihr habt mit sind
eigentlich
im gegenteil sogar das ist sogar
bestimmen diese eigentlich dieser flug
zu ende mit einigen tagen sünden zu
geraten
es geht
sind eigentlich meine verhältnisse seien
mit dem begriff sehr stark und hat eben
einen paten nichts zu tun
genau das muss noch nicht zu sehen man
kann
wirklich auch sagen diese taten sind
erscheinungsform dieses grundzustand und
so weiter aber wenn es aber ab sieht
diese tat so in der lage sind zu
vermeiden
dann ist gegen italien gibt es genug
ja ich denke das trifft sich gut mit
diesem koffer also ist nichts sind es
würden sie nichts punktuelles sünden
sind was solistisches oder was
relationale zustände
es gibt nur diese ist
es ist vielleicht
genau ist dessen existenz
äußerlichkeiten taxi dental oder so es
sind jetzt eine akzeptanz könnte man
schon fast sagen werde
alltags haben gegen die emotionale
verstimmungen und so weiter und wie man
das als sünde bezeichnet aus
und ich will das tun also
menschen
richtig aufregend klassiker als licht
und ins spiel und die menschen zu machen
moralische
die sünde nicht als objekt an die sünde
als subjekt oder als substanz könnte man
sagen so mit hegel letztendlich die
reinen resultate das ist als die reinen
fallbezogene betrachtungsweise die nur
auf die neue sünde sieht und das
dazwischen liegende dass zwischen den
einzelnen sünden liegende das
relationale überspringt ist eben so
oberflächlich wie wenn jemand annähme
ein eisenbahnzug bewege sich immer nur
dann wenn die lokomotive schnauft nein
dieses schnaufen und der vorstoß hat die
sünden der darauf folgt sind eigentlich
nichts das worauf man sehen soll sind
das gleichmäßige tempo mit dem die
lokomotive sich bewegt und dass jedes
schnaufen hervorbringt und so ist es mit
der sünde der zustand in der sünde ist
im tiefsten sind die sünde die einzelnen
sind sind nicht die fortsetzung der
sünde sind der ausdruck für die
fortsetzung der sünde in der einzelnen
19 ist das tempo der sinne nur ziemlich
leichter wahrzunehmen
interessant also hier die schöne
analogie oder metapher der stoß all
dieses schnaufen könnte man jetzt
vergleich mit einer sünde seiner
schlechten handlung das gleichmäßige
tempo das völlig uninteressante
eigentlich das völlig unspektakuläre da
kommt kein qualm raus da schon oft
nichts sondern dieses gleiten dieses
ganz unmerklich begleiten das ist das
entscheidend wie entscheiden ist
also diese existenz diese relation ali-t
genau psychologischen meisterhaft dass
shakespeares macbeth sagen lässt
südosten werke erlangen nur durch sünde
kraft und stärke das heißt es sünde ist
innerhalb ihrer selbst etwas
konsequentes und dieser konsequenz in
sich dass und in dieser konsequenz in
sicht des bösen hat sie auch eine
gewisse kraft seiner solchen
betrachtungsweise kommt man jedoch nie
wenn man nur auf die einzelnen sünden
sind also interessant ist hatte dass
konsequentes eine folgerichtigkeit eine
logik dass es letztendlich nicht
schelling schelling sagt auch es ist
eine perfektion die sich in bösen zeigt
er sagte das böse treten immer vom sind
in form von bösen redet jetzt hier eine
gewisse kraft
das ist wie der trinker den rausch von
tag zu tag ständig aufrecht erhält aus
furcht vor der stockung der mattigkeit
die eintreten würden und verehren
möglichen folgen wenn er in einen
einzigen tag so nüchtern bliebe so der
dämonische mensch ja sowie der gute
menschen wenn jemand sich ihm näherte um
ihn in versuchung zu führen und ihm die
sünde in der einen oder anderen
verlockenden gestalt darstellte in
anderen bitten würde bringen mich nicht
in versuchung so hat man wohl auch
beispiele ganzen gerade selben art von
einem dämonischen menschen
das lesen anschluss direkt gegenüber
jemandem der im guten stärker ist als er
kann die dämonische mensch wenn der
andere ihm das gute in seiner selige
erhabenheit darstellen will er sich
bitten unter tränen für sich bitte nicht
mit ihm zu reden ihn nicht wie es
ausdrückt schwach zu machen gerade weil
der dämonische schwenn mensch konsequenz
in sich und in der konsequenz des bösen
ist gerade deshalb hatte auch eine
totalität zu verlieren ein einziger
augenblick außerhalb seiner konsequenz
eine einzige diätetische
unvorsichtigkeit ein einziger blick zur
seite einen augenblick lang das ganze
oder nur einen teil davon auf andere
weise gesehen und verstanden und er
würde vielleicht nie mehr er selbst sagt
er
das heißt das gute hat er verzweifelt
aufgegeben
das kann ihm ohnehin nicht helfen wohl
aber könnte es im irren machen dass ihm
unmöglich machen jemals wieder in den
vollen schwung der konsequenz zu kommen
wie diese dampflokomotive also die
trägheit in schwachen machen nur in der
fortsetzung der sünde ist er er selbst
nur in ihr lebt er hatte den eindruck
seiner selbst aber was bedeutet dass es
bedeutet der zustand inter sünde ist das
was ihnen tief drunten wohin er gesunken
ist zusammenhält die durch die
konsequenz in einem schrecklichen szenen
stärkend nicht die einzelnen neue sünde
ja es ist ein grauenhafter wahnsinn
hilft ihm sondern die einzelnen neue
sünde ist nur der ausdruck für den
zustand in der sünde der eigentliche
sünde ist als wir es jetzt diese höchste
potenzierung hier will der dämonische
mensch in dieser inneren konsequenz
leben die diese konsequenz der sünde ist
sein identitäts prinzip und das gute ist
nur noch eine bedrohung
was ihn aus seiner inneren konsequenz
bringen könnte ja das kann man den
nächsten mal noch lesen also ich denke
wir haben jetzt im kicker fast
eigentlich wie mir scheint jetzt den
gipfel des bösen in seiner beschreibung
erlangt und zwar deswegen weil er es
nicht mehr nur als ein subjektives
phänomen fast ein verhältnis hat sich
das selbst verhält dann sind diese
größtmöglichen relational i tät
expliziert und eben auch so was wie es
und dämonischen menschen mal denken
lässt in den nächsten sitzungen werden
mit paul tillich eben dieses phänomen
des dämonischen mal als solches als eine
höchst form der sünde des bösen
thematisieren ja dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung